800 men and women at cdc have been
working
tirelessly to support this response
over the last uh 11 months now
as well as the other thousands of men
and women at cdc that have
stayed focused on the other critical
public health efforts that this agency
leads every day and it's been my great
privilege to have the opportunity to
lead them as you know the magnitude of
cdc's work
is unprecedented and we talked we made
over 2700 deployments to over 230 cities
we've published over 4 100 documents
we've helped distribute over 12.3
billion dollars of funding to our
state's
tribal local territory areas and you
know
one of the reasons we're here to talk
today this agency's worked hard
tirelessly to do its part of operation
warm speed for
cobia 19 vaccine distribution and most
importantly administration so that we
accomplish
vaccination i'm proud to say that early
this week
as you know i approve the
recommendations of cdc's advisory
committee on immunization practices to
recommend vaccination to both healthcare
personnel and residents of long-term
facilities in the initial phase of the
coven-19 vaccination program
i also look forward to the future
recommendations that based on vaccine
availability will
demonstrate that we as a nation also
prioritize the elderly people older than
70
who reside in multi-generational
households
often our hispanic black tribal nation
families
their care for their elderly is given in
these multi-generational households and
they are at a significant risk the
framework
that in addition to the ecip guidance i
think
as more vaccines available ensure
equitable distribution
of the vaccine for those at most at risk
for hospitalization fatalities
cdc as you witnessed yesterday in
tennessee continues to work with all 64
jurisdictions
to move from our planning process for
readiness for vaccine distribution which
we anticipate
will begin in the next several weeks
i'm optimistic that the fda will get
authorized vaccines within
the next several weeks and distribution
will begin
once the vaccines are authorized it'll
be a really critical new tool
to bring to the pandemic but i do also
say and this agency
stands strongly behind the efforts of
mitigation of wearing a mask watching
our social distancing washing our hands
and being smart about crowds
now finally mr president i personally
want to thank you
for your leadership as the head of the
white house paranoia's task force
your leadership really has brought as
you've said before
not just in all the government response
but in all of our
all of a nation response to this
pandemic and it's been remarkable
it's been a personal honor for me to uh
have you here at cdc and i would now
would like to turn the floor over to you
sir
well thank you very much dr redfield and
uh
dr walkey and dr messner and then all
the members of the cdc team
it is it's my honor to be here with you
first and foremost on behalf of
president donald trump
and all the members of the white house
coronavirus task force just to say thank
you
thank you to the men and women of cdc uh
who
who have literally poured their lives
over the last 10 months into saving
lives
across america i served as governor of
indiana and had
a reason to work with cdc in an incident
in the state of indiana
but the work that we have done together
over the last 10 months has left me
deeply inspired
not just as your vice president but as
an american
with the men and women that serve on
this campus on cdc campuses across
america and and literally the cdc
personnel that are embedded
all across this country giving counsel
to state policy makers and governors as
we've found our
way through this extraordinary
coronavirus
pandemic and its impact so i want to say
thank you to each and every one of you
i'm also very honored to be here
with three leaders who have been
stalwart partners
in our national response senator david
perdue
and senator kelly lefler i want to thank
you
whether it be the cares act whether it
be helping us to secure
billions of dollars to reinvent testing
provide ppe the establishment of the air
bridge or just your consistent
steady support to put the lives of the
people of georgia first i want to thank
you
and i thank you for being here for this
update i'm also very grateful to
congressman doug collins
um and uh all the members uh the house
of representatives who've
again stood with us uh put the health of
the american people first and it's an
honor to
have you join us for this for this
update
from the people here at cdc
we are we're in a challenging time
in the course of this pandemic and all
of us have a role to play
wash our hands social distance wear a
mask
when it's indicated but we're also in a
season of hope
this time of year is always filled with
hope through faith traditions and
in the hearts of the american people
especially our children but
to be as we are maybe bob just a week
and a half away
from what will be the likely approval of
the first coronavirus
vaccine for the american people is
inspiring the people of this country
and we we would not be here but
for the tireless efforts of everyone
involved in our national response
and especially for all the men and women
of the cdc
so i i look forward to an update thank
you for those
strong recommendations uh
from the acip that you
and the cdc have endorsed we're going to
put a priority
on our seniors and staff in our
long-term health care facilities
and we're also going to pray be a
priority on health care workers so that
we continue
not only to put their health first but
also make sure
that uh that we have the staff in our
hospitals and our clinics are under care
to americans that continue to be
impacted
by this pandemic but through operation
warp speed we'll be
working with governors around the
country to implement
those priorities and to distribute those
vaccines
quickly but i also want to say how
grateful we are for cdc's ongoing
council of the american people on
mitigation efforts
on what every american can do and even
the recent uh
adjustment in the amount of quarantine
time
taking it from the expectation of 10 to
14 days to seven days i know it was a
great encouragement to americans
but all along the way cdc has been
playing a
valuable role in advising
not only our administration but
administrations in every state
every territory in the nation and so on
behalf of
our president our administration on
behalf of
of all those stakeholders and the
american people just dr redfield
dr walkey dr messner the whole team here
at cdc looking on
just thank you for your deeply
compassionate
and dedicated service to the american
people because of all of you
help is on the way we can see the light
at the end of the tunnel
and i'm more confident than ever that
the day will come and come soon
when we put this coronavirus in the past
and return our nation uh to
the freedom and the health
uh and and the lifestyle that we've all
enjoyed
uh across this country so dr redfield
thank you very much for your kind words
and
i'll turn the program back over to you
thank you very much mr vice president
uh i think now uh senator madue you're
going to make some comments
well thank you dr redfield i appreciate
you and your leadership here at the cdc
hosting this roundtable and an
update on where we are your leadership
across your five
big platforms around the country and all
around the world
has meant so much to the administration
and all of us out here
in the real world relative to this
condemning so thank you for everything
the cdc has done we are
so proud to have you headquartered here
in atlanta and in georgia
but i want to call out the vice
president and the president as well for
their contribution here
mr president i want to thank you for
your leadership in this entire effort
i remember in days one when the
conversations in the white house were
talking about how do you limit travelers
coming back to the u.s how do you get
u.s citizens back in the u.s
we've progressed and learned a lot about
this fire since then but i really want
to call out operation warp speed
this is remarkable what you guys did
breaking through the red tape rather
regulations that were necessary going to
a sequential development
a parallel development rather than
sequential and just knock
years off the development of this
potential vaccine we're so excited about
the potential for an approval here in
the next few weeks but
it's on the back of development of
treatment regimens and regeneron and
been visibility and so forth that that
you guys have really broken through the
long jams and the bureaucracy to make
this happen so thank you as well
mr vice president thank you soon i'll
turn it back thank you thank you
senator laughlin thank you director
redfield and thank you for hosting us
here for this important day
mr vice president thank you so much for
your leadership of the coronavirus task
force
you and the president have shown america
what's possible here you've given us
hope
we saw the jobs report today that
america can and will get back on its
feet as you all promised you would help
bring us back we've done that
uh through the work of these great
agencies but also through the private
sector
and that partnership's been so important
the president
recognized that he's a business person
he understood how to engage the private
sector but also
hhs department of defense florida
and i was so pleased to be able to
support that work through the cares act
three trillion dollars of relief going
to hard-working americans
our hospitals our schools and my heart
goes out to all americans who are
impacted by this
those lives lost those that are ill
those small businesses that were shut
down and i know that you and the
president will keep fighting for
americans to come back from this
stronger than ever so thank you
thank you director redfield thank you
thank you all and thank you mr vice
president
and both of the senators i now would
like to uh really
introduce jay butler who's our deputy
director of infectious disease
jay also served as our one of our
incident managers
of the covenant response prior to henry
i've asked jay to give approximately jay
i think we've got about 18 20 minutes
before
we have to wrap up by one so to try to
sort of lead our discussion about
our vaccine preparation and distribution
efforts jeff
great well thank you dr redfield and let
me also extend my welcome and
appreciation mr vice president
uh senator loffler senator perdue and uh
congressman collins
it's really an honor to be able to host
you here
when we look at uh where we're at in the
pandemic response
uh mr vice president you used the word
hope i remember about nine months ago
we were talking about we hope we have a
vaccine
very soon and now we're really on the
verge of having a vaccine that will be
administered to americans
you're here at cdc i want to acknowledge
the partnership between cdc
and operation warp speed but also our
state local and tribal partners who are
really on the front line
of administering these vaccines and i
also want to point out that this is
bigger than an olive government
response it's an all-of-america response
it's going to take all of us at various
levels of government
also industry partners healthcare
providers and facilities as well as
community
faith-based organizations and leaders
so uh not to scare anybody but there is
a powerpoint
uh that might help to frame the
conversation
but i want to stress that i'd like this
to be conversational so
uh feel free to jump in if you have
questions
along the way so this the second slide
describes the overarching objectives of
the vaccination program
including to ensure that we have a safe
and effective vaccine
that will prevent the disease and death
caused by
covet 19 and also minimize the
disruption
to society to help restore the economy
and to be able to
protect our health care capacity which
is really groaning
under the stress of the pandemic
at this time but also to be able to
assure
equity in the vaccine allocation and
distribution
the pandemic has really shown a bright
light on some of the
inequities in health and we want to do
everything we can to be able to resolve
those
the third slide shows some of the
components of the vaccine implementation
but it includes uh just as uh you were
discussing
you made that point and when i was in
tennessee yesterday the head of the
hospital association
there are many heroes
in the midst of this pandemic the last
10 months of no more so than our doctors
and nurses and
people staffing our hospitals and
emergency rooms
and it would be altogether fitting for
the vaccine to go to them but i
your your point well made again
is that as we focus on the vulnerable
people in nursing homes and long-term
care facilities the people that work
there
the recommendation cdc's recommendation
to states
but making sure that as we see cases
rising hospitalizations rising that we
make sure that the staff
are protected or vaccinated and continue
to give that level of care
thank you yes you definitely want to
protect those that protect us
and also recognizing our health care
workforce is predominantly female
and some of the communities that
are heavily impacted by the pandemic
are actually overrepresented among
healthcare providers so
uh i think that is gonna the
prioritization of healthcare providers
will be important for
protecting not just the healthcare care
infrastructure
but also addressing some of these issues
that we've just raised
very good so the components of vaccine
implementation
include this process of identifying who
is going to be vaccinated first because
we will have
more people than we'll have vaccine
initially
allocating it out to the states and some
of the local jurisdictions to be able to
make sure that it's getting to where
it can be administered distributed in it
the logistics of getting it from the
factory to where it can be administered
and actually
also making sure that it gets into arms
and being able to track the safety and
because it's going to be two dose
regimens at least for the
initial vaccines making sure those
second doses are administered
and throughout all of that making sure
that we're communicating
what we know about the vaccine as
transparently as possible
and reassuring uh people that we're
telling them
what we know when we know it
the fourth slide goes into a little more
detail
about the advisory committee on
immunization practices
allocation methodology and it's a
deliberative process
using an external group of experts that
advise the cdc director
as a physician i'm going to say the ecip
is something i learned about very early
in my training and
it's where i go to learn more about how
vaccines should be utilized
uh so the question of which group should
be recommended to receive the vaccine
first there were four ethical principles
that were applied to maximize benefits
and minimize harm to be able to promote
justice and fairness in vaccine
distribution
to mitigate those health inequities and
also to promote transparency
incorporating what we know about the
science of the vaccines
when we know about the logistics of
implementing a vaccine particularly
these ultra-cold chain vaccines
and the ethics of making sure that it's
a fair process
the acip has met twice over the past
two weeks in public meetings and the
fourth slide
they're actually not a number but i
think it's an important slide that
outlines
some of the recommendations that came
out of those deliberations
and some of the data they looked at
included the fact that there's been
nearly a quarter
million token 19 cases among health care
providers
and unfortunately over 850 deaths
also looking at the data that we have on
long-term care facilities
and modeling those epidemiological datas
we know that vaccinating staff
can actually be very powerful way to be
able to save lives
and then also the exposure that occurs
in healthcare facilities not only
can put the healthcare providers at risk
of
disease but also because of the issues
around quarantine
and isolation take them out of the
workforce at a time when we desperately
need them
the next slide has a bar graph which i
think
says a lot about the process that the
acip went through
and recognizing that the risk of severe
illness goes up with increasing
age but we're not going to have enough
vaccine to vaccinate
all of our elders what this shows
is the proportion of covet associated
hospitalizations that come from
long-term care facilities
and among people age 75 and older
more than half come from long-term care
facilities
so that gives us an opportunity to
really identify where we will get the
biggest bang for our buck with those
initial doses of vaccine
so the next slide actually describes
those
phase one allocation groups including
health care personnel which we actually
clear about 21 million
in the united states that fit the broad
definition of health care provider
and roughly 3 million residents of
long-term care facilities
there's issues that we are continuing to
consider
as they say the devil is in the details
and this includes things like
sub-prioritization
which may be required if the supplies
are even more limited than we
think right now also implementing the
programs for healthcare personnel will
need to consider the fact that the
vaccines do cause some reactions and
sometimes
it's not uncommon for people to have a
sore arm although great fever
headache to feel tired and we want to
make sure that our health care workforce
is potentially delayed from continuing
to provide services
because of the vaccine itself so we're
providing
additional guidelines very soon on for
healthcare
organizations to know how to avoid
any problems from the reactorgenicity of
vaccine
we also know that reactogenicity appears
to be lower in an
older adult population so that's
i think potentially good news there is a
graph describing the distribution
concept
i'll summarize it by saying the pfizer
vaccine which requires ultra cold chains
the the one everybody says is antarctic
temperatures
will be shipped directly from the
manufacturer to selected sites that can
maintain that coal chain
in some states that may be only one or
two locations
the other vaccines such as the moderna
vaccine will go from the
factory to a distribution system that is
already existing
one that we use routinely for the
vaccine for children program
it's a system that already distributes
more than 80 million doses of vaccine
each year this will get the vaccine out
to different places where it will be
administered should also add that
it's not just vaccine that's showing up
but also the ancillary kits
whether it's needles syringes alcohol
swabs these kind of details that are so
important to be able to get vaccines not
just out of the
factory out into the states but also
making sure
it's getting into arms where it's going
to make a difference and dr butler
on operation warp speed i think it's an
encouragement to the american people
to know that while the scale
of the distribution of this vaccine
is historic
particularly in the time frame that
we're going to be driving
this is what cdc does every year i think
dr redfield you gave me a number
at a recent task force and i mean how
many how many vaccines is
cdc's distributed this system that we're
using with the customers as jason
we do over 80 million a year so i think
i think every american would be
comforted to know that cdc already
has been in the business of
of working with the private sector to
distribute
80 million vaccines every year and so
while our objective is to make the
vaccine available for every american
that we want it and we believe we'll be
in a position by the spring or early
summer
to have sufficient vaccinations for that
um that the confidence that i've i've
heard
from people that we're we're building on
a foundation
that that cdc is quite well versed in
and that
our private sector partners are very
experienced is that a fair comment
that's that's a fair statement and i
also just want to call out the foresight
of dr messier and her
her staff in the pre-pandemic planning
to build
into the contracts with mckesson
corporation that does the distributing
to be able to have the surge capacity in
the event of a pandemic so that we can
go
uh much higher than 80 million doses if
that's what we need to do yeah i think
nancy should correct it but i think when
you briefly
you had surge capacity up to maybe 900
million doses
is that the original contract well uh
and dr messina it's great to see you
again
a little while but continue to follow
your work and contributions here
how many states i was in tennessee
yesterday they actually had
been rehearsing pandemic planning they
told me over
the previous three years but with regard
to
our private sector partners and their
planning in states
how much planning had gone into this
long before anybody ever heard of cove
at 19.
can you address that nancy yeah i think
that
that you know every state has been
working on identity planning for many
years but
that really kicked in the idea of the
h1n1 and then
which actually dr butler led the
immunization efforts for
and i think that the point is that while
this is a
unforeseen scale the building blocks of
this
existed not only at cdc but in every
state in jurisdiction
i think that's what's been most
inspiring to me bob
and uh i've talked about during the team
the the forethought the anticipation the
the history
of cdc's role
in preparing for and dealing with
previous outbreaks
we're building on all of that with this
i think it gives all of us great
confidence about
the ability to hit our marks in
operation work speed so
go ahead and dr i just want to amplify
that with you
thank you sir and i think i can add for
uh dr
smith who is the health commissioner in
arkansas and from my own experience as
health commissioner in alaska
the support of cdc was critical for the
statewide and local
as well as tribal preparedness for what
we're dealing with now
there's a slide that describes a little
more of the details of the pfizer
and uh moderna products i think the only
thing i'll point out
is that it's not straightforward it's
not as easy as
2009 and one dose of influenza vaccine
it's two doses it's different intervals
it's different handling so there's quite
a bit of
education that we are putting together
for providers
as well as some fairly complicated data
tracking to be able to make sure
we're direct we're direct shipping
vaccines to providers
the the product is direct shipping and
then the mederna product
is going through the mckesson process
but it's a fast
process it doesn't slow down both of
them end up at the provider
that's correct um which which is really
remarkable on the sense of um
what general purna was briefing us on
just a couple weeks ago was we as we're
encouraging states
to enroll more providers then we have
the ability through either system
to ultimately have that vaccine arrive
at that provider however large or small
they are so that's how we we actually
believe
and that uh from the moment that
we receive fda approval which we think
is likely
sometime the week of the 14th of
december
that we we could be shipping within the
first 24 hours and we could be
vaccinating
people within 24 hours of that so within
48 hours
from the fda's approval we could be
vaccinating people
literally in all 50 states and
and territories all across the country
so it's a and
this is all being overseen by the cdc uh
and the experienced people here so
really remarkable
um the next page shows actually the
number of vaccine providers who are
enrolled to be able to administer
vaccines
uh this is only through this past monday
now i want to stress that even though
the number exceeds 10
000 this is not you know a single person
with a
needle and syringe in hand these are
includes
organizations that may represent dozens
if not
hundreds of people who are administering
vaccine
uh we've been working with our uh states
to make sure we're getting feedback what
are the problems that what are you
mostly hearing
um because we we deal the task force
deals with
all the nation's governors virtually on
a weekly basis i was speaking to a
governor on my way from the airport
what what's the feedback right now what
are the issues that they're raising
right now
well sorry there's uh six issues that we
see as recurring things one is the
funding issue
to make sure that they have
uh the ability to be able to operate
the local program right and that
includes having enough people to
administer the vaccine while we're
leaning heavily
on providers as well as partners like
walgreens
or cbs there's going to be situations
where we need
a larger workforce to actually
administer the vaccine
an issue we hear maybe not so much from
the governors but from the
vaccine program people is recognizing
that
the week of the 14th is only the
beginning of the beginning
this is a process that's going to play
out over the next several months
and we need to develop what the cadence
will be
how do we make this a sustainable
process because this will be
a marathon and not a spread
the other issues that have come up is
making sure that we have
everything in place as i was mentioning
earlier about the second dose planning
that there is enough vaccine so that no
one receives a dose and then is told
there's no more available for your
booster
uh making sure that the people who are
administering vaccine remain
safe that there's personal protective
equipment
available we think we by the end of the
month we could have 40 million doses
but we're going to literally hold back
the second dose so the focus would be on
getting about
20 million americans vaccinated but
as you said the priority will be to make
sure that everybody knows if you get the
first shot
you're going to be in the system and
we're already holding in reserve
the second dose for you so american
people can be confident of that but that
that's an issue that you're hearing
about yes and that but that's a
priority that we want to address and we
want to keep our vaccinators safe so we
want to make sure that the ppe is
available to them
we're providing a small amount to them
as well but also working with them to
make sure the stocks are available
and then addressing the issue about
vaccine confidence that
people feel like it's going to be a safe
and protective vaccine
and as a health care provider and a
public health official i know that the
person that most people listen to most
is their health care provider right
so we want to make sure that information
is uh
provided to health care providers as
quickly as possible
particularly since they're prioritized
so that they can confidently receive the
vaccine
and then also serve as examples for
their patients
well the confidence piece is so
important and we did see some positive
progress but
this fall i think in september we only
had half of the american public that
said they'd be prepared to take a
vaccine
i think that's closer to 60 percent now
and rising
but i know i want to be sensitive to
everyone's time
i know you're initiating a project to
build
confidence in the vaccine and
i think it's incumbent
on all of us in public life to
communicate the thorough
process we've gone at a record pace
uh but we've cut no corners
uh in this i think that what we want to
do is assure the american people there's
been no
no no you know compromise of safety
or effectiveness in the development of
this vaccine we just
under operation warp speed we as senator
perdue said very well we
for the first time ever we did several
things at the same time we
literally were manufacturing vaccines
while they were being
developed and screened and reviewed so
that that's what puts us in a position
to have
the the 40 million doses that we could
have before the end of this month
but i just want to urge you all on in
that i know that
dr redfield and i have spoken about it
you said there's no more trusted voices
than your local healthcare provider i
think cdc's voice
in continuing to reassure the american
public
about the safety of this vaccine would
be
extremely important so i want to
encourage you in that
nancy could probably make a quick
comment that you know
clearly has been working prior to covid
to build our confidence and vaccination
with influenza
which obviously then laid the groundwork
for this and in addition
people may not be aware but the cdc in
partnership with the fda
really has an extensive vaccine adverse
reporting system
that we operate on all vaccines and i
think that's also part of the importance
of
building confidence that we have this
transparent adverse reporting system
nancy i don't know if you want to make a
comment or two about it
dr cohen it's actually her uh her thing
amanda
sure so um that's nate with confidence
program it's really a national strategy
to support
increasing confidence you can step
forward doctor if you like so we
can see it um the um the national
vaccine uh
confidence program uh is being initiated
by cdc and all of our federal
partners to reinforce trust in the
american public which means we need to
not only monitor safety as much as
possible as robustly as all of our
systems
will give us all of that data but we
also have to communicate that to the
public on a regular basis
the most important thing we can also do
is empower
health care providers as dr butler said
healthcare providers
if they take the vaccine and they show
everyone that they have
taken the vaccine and that it's been a
um
and they support and recommend
vaccination they will
um they will uh infuse uh confidence in
the american public
um i always say we have uh 200 uh
we have 20 million health care providers
and each one of them instills confidence
in 10 people we will we will get there
and finally engaging communities is the
last part of our strategy which is
really important to reach communities
that have health disparities that may
not trust
the government in the same way that
other groups do and we really have to
address them using local partnerships um
addressing them with listening to
people's
questions and concerns about the vaccine
i think
um several people have said i don't want
people to tell me what to do i want
people to talk to me about what to do
um and so we're really going to use uh
as dr butler said all of
america approach um we need not only
government and health care providers but
also
local community trusted sources uh to
help us increase confidence
that's great doc and it's dr cohn
and so all of that information will be
public to the american people
adverse effects people can report in if
they have an adverse effect of vaccine
and
and so people would be able to track
virtually in real time
um how people are responding
to the vaccine and they've got to be a
great comfort uh country
and i really want to commend you for
that great job
excellent job um dr butler i might
just jump in here because i wanted to
hear a little bit from dr walkey just a
big picture for the
i know the senators and and the
congressmen are
in the process of looking at possibly
additional resources i'd love to give
give dr walkee a chance to say where we
are where we are
nationally i think we in the emergency
operations center we just got a briefing
that we're seeing
cases coming down across the heartland
but we're starting to see
upward trends uh in the in the south and
in
uh other major metropolitan areas in the
northeast
so i'd love to get your sense of that
but let me let me just say dr butler i
want to thank you
for your years of dedicated service but
especially this year
uh and the difference that you've made
and we'll continue to make here though
we're all grateful and we're all
grateful to you personally and
look forward to continuing to to work uh
to the day that we put the coronavirus
in the past so thank you very much
dr walker you want to give us uh give us
all a quick
thumbnail of where we stand today
um and uh and how you might how you
might best advise the task force or the
policy makers that are here yeah thank
you so much for the opportunity mr mike
vice president um as you saw in the eoc
yes there are some positive signs in the
overall
in some of the jurisdictions for example
the midwest and the plains
we're starting to see the cases uh come
down certainly in some of the larger
population centers
in the west and the northeast we're
still seeing the cases go up
so that's the cases hospitalizations or
you know hospitalizations follow cases
um increasing cases by about a week or
two weeks
so the hospitalizations are still rising
um and
it's it's a real problem healthcare
providers are overstretched
beds are full and so we need to
try to prevent hospital strain and the
way to do that really
is to is for americans to to
to lean in and use a mask wash their
hands
maintain their distance avoid crowded
indoor
unventilated spaces and get tested
you know we just released for example
our domestic travel guidance
that emphasizes before you travel and
after you travel
there's a consider getting tested before
you get on a plane especially for an
international flight
and then when you return make sure that
you're you're staying at home for a
period of time
up to seven days so you make sure you're
not infecting other people
we did just reduce the um the quarantine
um we we still say if 14 days is
probably the safest
for for quarantine but we give an option
for 10
days without a test and seven days now
with the test
recognizing that health health
departments are overwhelmed with the
number of case investigations and the
contact tracing so
i think this moment so if someone is a
close contact that
they know about or that they just may
suspect
um that they were exposed if they get a
test at the
at the end of seven days
they actually
they can actually get tested at five
days for example
so you could get tested five days after
a close contact
with a confirmed case you're tested five
days and that could either be with a
rapid antigen test where you can get
the result back in 15 minutes or with a
molecular test like a pcr test which
your result will come back in the next
day or two
if you if that test is negative then you
can release you can
you can be released from quarantine
after seven days
so seven days of quarantine with the
test ten days without a test
um so i think as our hospitalization
beds are
are filling up the deaths are still
rising
um obviously and these are the cases in
some areas arising as well
what we can do now is try to prevent
infections um
and again as we move into the holiday
season
i i would encourage the american public
to consider staying at home it's
it's a very tough um advice
but we're concerned about the the rising
cases and the impact on our hospital
systems
so whatever we can do at the personal
level at the community level
to prevent infections we should do that
we just released an mmwr today
that goes over 10 different strategies
to at this moment in the pandemic where
there's a rise in
transmission all the things that
communities and and
individuals can do to try to to try to
prevent from increasing this
transmission
that's available at the cdc's website
it's being released today right
just this afternoon so please take a
look at it but appreciate the
opportunity
can i just ask one question maybe dr
redfield might take this or
doctor as we move
let's assume and i we remain very
optimistic
if dr redfield's optimistic our team is
that we may have approval in a week and
a half of a vaccine
if we we are successful in vaccinating
20 million americans particularly the
most
some of the most vulnerable and
long-term care facilities are healthcare
workers
um what impact is that on the
course of the pandemic and when when do
you
excuse me when would you expect to see
an impact
on the pandemic as we roll the vaccine
out
well um and i'll start but i'll please
them and i mean in terms of its overall
impact on the right
country well just in terms of the
long-term care residents about 40
percent of all deaths are linked to
long-term care residents
so by vaccinating those we're going to
see a decrease in deaths
in the future and as vaccine becomes
more and more available
then eventually we're going to see a
decrease in cases
and approach this level of herd immunity
but in terms of when the timing
as you know we're going to we have about
40 million doses probably by the end of
the year
we'll have more that'll come on board
and so we'll need to continue these
mitigation measures
and the spacing washing our hands
wearing a mask
probably well into the spring until we
get more widely available vaccine
but dr butler did you want to say
anything else to that or dr walk i'll
just
add that we're on an excellent course
right now
with two vaccines that are looking very
promising
and there's but there's a number of
unknowns that i want to acknowledge
those in terms of whether or not the
production will
be able to continue without interruption
and we also depend heavily on some of
the other products that are currently in
trials and we don't yet have the data on
those
so it'll be a matter of being able to
provide
protective immunity to as many americans
as possible
and being able to assess how that is uh
driving the
the pandemic downward and ultimately
that will then lead to additional
recommendations about
whether or not we can change our current
guidelines on mass
social distancing than hand hygiene i
understand
and i would just add that one of the big
thrusts that i think we're
we're really confronting right now with
a variety of strategies
is to do all we can to keep our health
system from being overwhelmed
and i think that is the critical thing
for december and january
and all of these things will contribute
obviously getting the nursing home
residents vaccinated in december when
they
make up such a significant point of
hospitalizations
we'll start to see that impact you know
in late
late january getting our health care
workers
to make sure that they don't have to
isolate and quarantine
we won't see that contribution so i
think that's the added
and mr vice president i just want to
thank you i know you have a busy
schedule
i want to thank you for taking the time
i want to just reiterate
uh the honor it's been to work with you
on the task force and your leadership
in that i want to thank you for coming
here to acknowledge the incredible men
and women
at cdc that work 24
7 and they will continue to guide our
nation's
response to the pandemic after we're
gone
and i have great confidence in them and
we will soon see as you know the
beginning of really what
uh is in my view nearly miraculous
that we're going to begin to see the
distribution of a safe and efficacious
vaccine
as you said the other day in tennessee
we can now say
in in the near days ahead we don't no
longer have to say months or
it's in the days ahead so i want to
thank you for the time i know
it's meant a lot to the men and women at
cdc and i think you can
get a sense that there's a great group
of individuals
behind the scenes driving this national
response
at cdc and this team is
you know well prepared to help guide the
distribution and administration this
vaccine
as you heard this is what they do it's
kind of like at fedex the other day they
do what they do
this is what they do the american public
needs to know
nancy and her team amanda and others are
distributing 80 million doses of vaccine
a year with the same company that we
brought into this
there are some additional complexities
but this team is up to it and i have
great confidence that this vaccine
distribution
is going to be highly successful so well
thank you dr redfield and to the whole
team here at cdc including those that
are looking on
just thank you for your
dedication thank you for your compassion
thank you for your professionalism
i i couldn't be more inspired with what
i've seen from early on whether it be
when we were reinventing testing or when
we were giving guidance to
essential workers to be able to stay in
the workplace to keep
all of all of america's essential
businesses and services rolling
to open companies back up that were
that we're seeing outbreaks the guidance
that you gave
through those 45 days and the guidance
you continue to give
americans and and now to see
to see the way cdc is continuing to play
a shepherding role over
operation warp speed and to make sure
that we have a safe and effective
vaccine that we deliver to the american
people as quickly as possible is
uh tremendously inspiring so dr butler
thank you dr messner great to see you
again
uh dr walkey i know our incident
commander thank you
for all the long hours that you've
put in and i want to thank the senator
leffler and senator perdue
again three trillion dollars in support
for american families and american
businesses and american health care
providers
and to congressman collins as well you
all have been extraordinary partners
uh on behalf of the american people
through this but
i'll uh i'll just end by saying dr
redfield tonight um
have become very good friends through
this process and he is a man of
integrity
uh and uh i just couldn't be more
grateful
that dr robert redfield was leading cdc
at such a time as this
and it gives me great confidence that
help is on the way we all have a role to
play
we'll continue to play it we'll continue
to all of us do our part
but from dr redfield on down the
american people owe a debt
uh owe a debt of gratitude and honor to
the men and women of the cdc here and
around the country so
thank you and god bless you all thank
you mr vice president
thank you very much
great job
thank you